today we remember and celebrate the
friends who weren't just there for us
during the good times but we're also
there for the bad ones to you we say
thank you thank you thank you for
holding my hair back as I puked in the
toilet and on your shoes a little bit
for letting me borrow your jacket for
five years without you knowing for
helping me move that dead body before
anyone could see for that time when you
shared your fake ID with me for loaning
me money when I needed to buy shovels to
dig that hole is anybody else hearing
this guy today we honor you for blocking
creepy guys from talking to me at the
club for helping me build a shed over
the hole so nobody would look there do
you hear that or is it is it just me for
taking my phone away when I started
drunk texting my ex's new girlfriend
seriously I mean it's not like I kill
anybody but this dude trying to cheat at
checkers for only posting pics where I
look good too so are we just gonna act
like it's not happening I'm saying man
board games his life so if you try to
cheat me out of a board game you try to
cheat me our life for that be safe thank
you thank you thank you thank you and if
you ever tell anybody what you know
about me just remember I know your
secrets too happy Friendship Day happy
Friendship Day happy Friendship Day
happy Friendship Day no snitches
you